is there a correlation between any of  the characteristics of these uaps UFOs  and some other characteristic for  example let's say that the Tic Tac  shaped ones are more violent or the  pyramidal shaped ones are faster is  there a classification of them and do  they have some other characteristic  associated with them what we tend to see  are the the smaller Vehicles tend to be  uh think of a sports car are you are  your uh saucer shaped Vehicles whereas  the larger Vehicles let's say a school  bus size is that of a of a cylindrical  object or roughly that of a Tic Tac or  even sometimes described as a telephone  pole and then in shape so cylindrical  and then the the tend to be the large  ones where the large ones tend to be uh  not always but almost exclusively either  triangular shape or Boomerang shape